welcome
what are you boy
what's up everybody if you are
interested in resident evil in the whole
Resident Evil series do we have a treat
for you we are so excited about Resident
Evil 7 coming up aren't we Mike yeah we
are pretty pumped for it so we decided
we would kind of preface it with a
really long several months of playing
the entire series every part of the
series from 1 through 6 even though you
we are both huge fans there's a bit of a
difference between me and Mike I haven't
played through all of them yeah I've
played every single one all the numbered
entries I play zero plague code Veronica
if you can played the on Rails umbrella
and Wesker Chronicles games we are
choosing to stick with the remasters
though which I understand the remake and
the first game are very different but in
the interest of time and the interest of
a better stream we're just gonna stick
to starting with remake it's gonna be
good guys so you're not gonna want to
miss any of these so be sure to stay
tuned to Resident knievel every week
here on GameSpot